[Musique]
iggy pop est cher jodie foster au nom du
festival de cannes
connu de la france vous avez
reconnaissante de l'amour que vous avez
c'est de témoigner
mélina lumière sa langue au nom des
amoureux du cinéma du monde entier j'ai
eu plaisir de vous inviter sur scène
pour bull renault la palme d'or
d'honneur du festival de cannes
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
merci
la foule infiniment vous tous le
festival de cannes pierre lescure
thierry frémaux a les spectateurs mes
amis parmi vous ma femme alexandra à ma
partenaire en pyjama c'est c'est
vraiment un grand honneur d'être choisi
pour marquer ce moment unique dans
l'histoire du festival
il ya plus que il ya plus de 45 ans que
mon film taxi driver a gagné la palme
d'or et je suis si reconnaissant de cet
endroit magique qui a lancé ma carrière
c'était avec un grand amour que
j'accepte cet honneur
on t'aurait de ma tribu qu'est-ce que
vous êtes bien beau ce soir c'est vrai
les êtres humains à la suite d'une année
nique et un est au début d'une année
bâtisse est inconnue mais quand même
de retour dans cette salle pour se
nourrir de cinéma et qu'est-ce que je
suis fier de faire partie de cette
communauté
et qu'est-ce que j'ai hâte de voir ce
que le futur nous apportent ensemble
toujours ensemble je vous remercie du
fond de mon coeur
merci
[Applaudissements]